only on CBS this morning two men who say
that Michael Jackson sexually abused
them as children are opening up about
their experiences with the pop icon Wade
Robson and James safe chucker featured
in an explosive new documentary that
premieres this weekend on HBO
both men also sued the Jackson estate
but their lawsuits were dismissed
because of the statue of limitations
they are appealing that Jackson has
always denied any inappropriate behavior
with children Robson and safe Chuck told
us about their relationships with
Jackson including very graphic
allegations of abuse or warning here
some of these details are quite
disturbing
before you all met Michael Jackson what
did he mean to you I saw the making of
thriller just instantly became obsessed
I wanted to be just like and I dressed
like him every day and did my hair and
had my hair permed to look like him and
you know all that stuff I wasn't
necessarily a big fan and then when I
got the commercial the Pepsi Company had
a Pepsi commercial when you see me meet
them is actually my first time seeing
him you know at that point I was pretty
excited was otherworldly I guess James
safe Chuck and Wade Robson discuss the
intimate details of their relationships
with Michael Jackson
everybody wanted to meet Michael or be
with Michael in the upcoming HBO
documentary leaving Neverland that's the
name of Jackson's Ranch were Robson
claims seven years of sexual abuse with
the world-famous performer first began I
mean this was just the most magical
thing I'd ever seen and that first night
Michael kind of took us on a little bit
of a tour and he said to me and my
sister you can stay in one of the guest
rooms or you can stay in here with me if
you want my reaction was of course I
want to stay with you we had one more
night that way the myself and my family
we're gonna leave and go on another kind
of vacation to the Grand Canyon I was
devastated to leave Michael Michael was
devastated for me to leave he actually
sobbed say you got to stay so I got to
stay and so it was just Michael and I
and Neverland for the next week
and your parents allowed that my parents
allowed that within even the first or
second night of Michael and I being
alone at Neverland the nights started
changing one of the ways I remember it
starting is you know Michael just sort
of starting to touch my legs and touch
my crotch over my pants it progressed to
him performing oral sex on me him
showing me how to perform oral sex on
him did it scare you did you think it
was wrong
a couple days prior to the abuse
starting he started touching me just in
the sense of like Pande on my leg
lots of hugs kissing my forehead rubbing
my hands so there had been this kind of
development of physical closeness that
was happening already that felt like a
father it just felt amazing as Michael
started doing these sexual acts he
started talking to me about God brought
us together we love each other and this
is how we love each other we love each
other and this is how we show each other
our love James you're nodding in
agreement to what he's saying tell me
what happened to you he introduced me to
masturbation he said I taught him out of
French kiss and then it moves on to oral
sex you frightened or thinking this is
weird or wrong no no it's in the context
of a loving close relationships there's
no alarm bells going off in your head or
there any thoughts like that really it's
just I love this person and and we're
trying to make each other happy he said
I was this first but even as a kid you
don't even know what that means so your
lovers and your best friends what does
that mean James you're in a relationship
in your lover's you're a little boy
right and he's a 30-something man and
you're a little boy cuz at that age how
do you even know what that means
you don't you just feel really connected
to someone and you just love them
intensely the public in general thinks
it's violent that it's very painful but
what you're describing is totally the
opposite of that I mean he didn't beat
me he didn't you know he'd never said
mean things to me it was all we love
each other in spite of what they're
claiming today in 1993 both Robson and
safe Chuck denied being molested by
Jackson when allegations were brought by
another boy jordan chandler that case
settled out of court you all both tell a
very descriptive story about you know
sexual activity was Michael Jackson yet
when you were asked to testify in 2005
and Wade you did you got on the stand
and you testified in his behalf and
vehemently denied that any sexual
activity had taken place yes why did you
do that the training Michael's training
of me to testify began the first night
that he started abusing me he started
telling me that if anybody else ever
finds out we'll both go to jail both of
our lives will be over the 2005 criminal
trial of Michael Jackson centered on
molestation charges brought by child
cancer survivor named Gavin Arvizo
court testimony shows that from the
stand Wade Robson denied ever kissing
showering or even cuddling with Jackson
you know they credit your testimony in
part for Michaels acquittal you know you
were called really a star witness you
you withstood a blistering
cross-examination and he was acquitted
on some level do you feel guilty about
that now do you think about that yeah I
do think about that I have and I do I
wish that I was ready I wish that I
could have helped
Gavin Arvizo received some justice and
some validation for what happened to him
that was just like what happened to me
and just like what happened to James and
I wish that I could have played a role
in at that point
stopping Michael from abusing however
many other kids he did after that do you
think that there are others out there I
do think there are others out there but
but I also don't expect them to just
come out now that we're coming out it's
such a difficult thing to do to come out
you have to do it when you're ready we
can't change what happened to us it
happened it's done but what can we do
with it now how can we provide comfort
for other survivors that's what this is
about and Michael just happens to be the
guy the abuser in this child sexual
abuse story no you know we talked to the
Jackson family yesterday and they say
these men we should point out again
according to the Jackson family they're
admitted liars and opportunists we're
now trying to capitalize on Michael
Jackson's death and exploit exploit the
Jackson name neither one of these men
were paid for appearing in the
documentary they will get nothing for
appearing but they think it's important
they say to tell their story and they
want people to know and I thought it was
interesting when they said when you
think of child sexual abuse you think
that it's a very frightening painful
thing but for them they didn't even know
that anything wrong was happening to
them because they're little boys you
can't overlook the detail about how that
relationship evolved and what's so
powerful about the detail is not the act
it's a narrative and the fact that both
of them didn't know each other and they
did heard a version of the same very
surprising and complicated narrative
from or they claimed from Michael
Jackson and that those two things are
similar and each one of them said they
thought they were the only one in
keeping the secret keeping the secret is
the thing that often takes you down I've
said it before a lot of problems using
Fosters in silence exactly and it's only
until people begin to speak out about it
and expose it that it starts to end and
that's why they're speaking up